why hello there
i'm your friendly neighborhood youtube
host dave rubin and this
is the reuben report direct message for
march
1st 2021 that's right guys we are in the
third month of 2021 and you may remember
that in march of 2020 that's when we
were told
two weeks to flatten the curve that was
officially a year ago
this month and we still ain't there
we don't even talk about the curve
anymore no more curve we're on to some
other stuff
anyway guys this is a huge week i think
i think there's a lot
happening sort of in the world this week
but it's a huge week
i would say for me personally for this
show for a lot of the ideas that we're
talking about if you haven't seen it
already we just released part one
of my two-hour interview with jordan
peterson
to say that there's a lot to catch up on
would be the understatement of the
century
two hours with j.p we talk about
the tour we talk about addiction we talk
about his struggles we talk about his
comeback
obviously we spend a good portion of it
talking about this right here his new
book which comes out tomorrow
beyond order 12 more rules for life if
you thought 12 were enough
you were wrong there's 12 more and he's
actually got a couple other rules
on the way that are coming out but he's
he's coming back
it it was uh well let me just say this
way i mean chatting with him
for those two hours although we've we've
texted a bunch we've talked on the phone
a bunch in these last two years
i did see him once in the midst of all
of this
um to sit down with him again and
unfortunately we had to do it via skype
because in canada you can't i was going
to travel there but they're not even
letting people travel in i was going to
go do it there obviously
i wanted to sit down with jp live but uh
just wasn't in the cards this time
but just to even be able to do this
thing with him uh
and and see him back it feels right to
me it feels like a little order
has been put back into the universe and
we've we've needed it desperately so
part one
of our interview is up on youtube right
now if you want to watch the full two
hours right now
they're up also at
reubenreport.locals.com and of course
we'll be putting it on youtube but
it's uh it's up early and ad-free over
on
our locals community uh oh and before i
get to all the stories of today and
we're mixing it up
trump came back biden had another sort
of horrific
mix-up and a whole bunch of other stuff
but before we get to all the stories
uh tomorrow los angeles i'm doing a live
meetup that's right i'm going to drink
and potentially eat with real human
beings
uh we're going to announce this in our
locals community uh for subscribers only
so
you got to subscribe to get the ac to
get the location
and then i will meet you there and we
will drink and we will eat and the
the restaurant slash bar that we're
doing it at
is actually owned by a guy who i met at
one of the protests to open up the state
and uh he's a restaurateur who owns many
different establishments owns a couple
bars couple restaurants
and uh he basically i met him at one of
the things and he was talking about
having to lay off all these people
and all the struggles he was going
through and i said to him this is now
two three months ago i said him hey
when i do a live meet up we're going to
do it at one of your places so we
we found a spot that i think uh is
appropriate
and uh we'll be announcing that in the
community later today so if you're in
socal and you want to say hi to me and
have a drink and
maybe have some wings or some burgers or
something
uh it'll all be at
okay we got one ad for you and then we
are going to jump into the stories guys
when you're running a business hr issues
can kill you wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements
labor regulations the list goes on and
on and hr manager salaries are not cheap
on an average of 70 000 a year bambi
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for small
businesses you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr policy and maintain
compliance all for just 99
a month with bambi you can change hr
from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat
from onboarding to terminations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day
all for just 99 a month month to month
no hidden fees cancel any time
if you're like me then i know you didn't
start your business because you wanted
to spend time on
hr compliance that is an understatement
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today go to bambi.com
ruben to schedule your free hr audit
that's bambi.com
reuben spelled bam to the b-e-e
dot com reuben and now back to me all
right guys so if you did not
see it in florida i believe it was in
orlando cpac the conservative political
action committee convention
i added an extra c there uh was
happening and this
is where they get all the big
conservatives everybody shows up they
kind of lay out the agenda going forward
but that's all a sideshow because uh
this donald trump fellow remember him
orange guy crazy hair been m.i.a for the
last two months got booted off spotify
youtube twitter facebook pinterest and
the rest of it
uh he returned yesterday uh gave
a incredibly long speech managed to kiss
the flag
all the usual trump stuff we're gonna
show you uh two
clips of the video and uh and then we'll
go from there
uh so at first he talked about the
election now before i play this clip
i do just want to say i'm just uh
playing donald trump's words and if
you're a youtuber youtube regulator or
susan wojcieck the
ceo of youtube i'm just playing a video
of something that the former president
of the united states said and i'm at
your humble
humble uh well what would you call it
i'm i'm just
here to play video and not really
comment on it specifically as a guy that
comments for a living
let's take a look horrible things are
happening
that are too voluminous to even mention
but people know i mean it's being
studied and
the level of dishonesty is not to be
believed we have a very sick and corrupt
electoral process that must be fixed
immediately this election was rigged and
the supreme court and other courts
didn't want to do anything about it
[Applause]
all right so those are the words of
donald trump this election was rigged
i'm not even commenting on that
specifically at this point i don't mean
that because of
the the youtube situation right i mean
this is why we put all our videos on
on locals anyway um there's some
interesting things happening even this
week now
uh atlanta uh sorry georgia although
it's specifically happening in atlanta
is looking at their election security
there are different states now looking
at their election security so hopefully
regardless of what you believe happened
regardless of what actually happened
during the election
hopefully we can tighten up our our
elections in general and
and give them a higher level of
transparency
because the very people who said four
years ago the election was
rigged are the very people who say you
can't look at it now and it could have
been vice versa if we had just done it
the other way
so i think in general making sure we
have
more transparent elections making sure
more people
believe that the process is valid
is legit i think that is basically good
but
it was interesting to me because i was a
little surprised that trump went down
that path during the speech because that
sort of
in essence the ship has sailed meaning
the ship for the last election
obviously has sailed right we're we're
we've moved on
joe biden is the president of the united
states whether you like him or not so i
was a little surprised to see
trump do that uh trump then went on to
to
go right back into the culture wars
surprise surprise and he had this to say
about trans women in sports all of a
sudden somebody comes along and beats it
by a hundred pounds
now young girls and women are in sense
that they are now being forced to
compete against those who are
biological males it's not good for women
it's not good for women's sports which
worked so long and so hard to get to
where they are
the records that stood for years even
decades are now being smashed with ease
smashed if this has not changed
women's sports as we know it will die
they'll end it'll end if you miss
nothing else about trump i mean just the
little body motions you know just
like just just that is good enough um
look the reason i wanted to play this
clip is because
this culture war stuff is just not going
anywhere you may have seen that even
last week amazon decided to ban
a book related to transgender issues and
young people
transitioning as you guys know i've had
abigail shiron who wrote a phenomenal
book about
the sort of epidemic of young girls
transitioning
her whole point is there's nothing wrong
with being trans but then when we see
massive numbers of in this case young
girls transitioning it's something to
look at it's something that we can we
should honestly be able to discuss and
then when you
look at things like having you know the
the health
and the health is it the health and
homeland secretary not health and
homeland security but the
the deputy uh health secretary uh this
rachel levine she being
uh going through the nomination process
last week talking about how young
children should be given puberty
blockers
and it should be up to the children not
to the parents it's like it's just like
another sort of unfurling of so many of
the things that we're
seeing right now and and again no matter
how many times you discuss this if you
talk about it at all they're going to
call you a transfer they're going to
call you bigger and all that
but in essence of course we all know
that what trump said there
is correct if you if you believe that
men and women should have different
sports right like if you believe the nba
should be a male league
and the wnba should be a female league
well then you would want
biological men to play in one and
biological women
to play in another because there are
biological differences that's not to say
one is better
generally men are bigger and stronger or
faster women can give birth to babies
like that's a pretty good thing too
i like that thing that's a nice thing
and and being big and strong is good too
and obviously you're gonna have
variations in all of those things
but if you want to see biological men
beat up girls if you want to see
biological boys who transition to female
own all of the girls high school sports
and college sports records
and if you want to see biological men
dunking on women in the wnba
well then how is that the feminist
position how is that the pro-female
position and and
of course this is just an extension of
watching the many waves of feminism
ultimately you know sort of going for
progress okay we got progress now we
start going around and we
and we go to regress so suddenly
watching a big
biological male crush a young girl in
wrestling somehow that is supposedly
the feminist position so his line was
it's not good for women it's not good
for women sports
that's true now i didn't hear him say
anything i listened to the rest of the
clip
i didn't hear him say anything against
trans people generally and you may
remember about
two years ago when when the trans thing
was getting real hot uh trump was asked
about
bathrooms you know there was that whole
bathroom brouhaha well that had actually
started under the obama campaign
or under the obama administration and
then i believe in north carolina
uh they wanted obama was going to
withhold federal funds from north
carolina unless they added bathrooms or
something
and trump was asked about it and trump
basically said look i'm a hotel builder
i don't care what
bathroom you go into and actually if we
only had one bathroom that would save me
on
construction costs so in that regard i
think he's just a realist but
the the wider issue of of this trans
thing it's such a bizarre
thing and i've discussed this not only
with abigail schreier but with douglas
murray
uh who wrote extensively about it in the
madness of crowds
and and several other people that it's
this thing that's being pushed on to us
that that affects this tiny portion of
people who i would never want
discriminated against
but suddenly boys should be in women's
bathrooms
children should decide whether they're
going to get puberty blockers or not
it's just like another thing that sort
of whittles away at everything that
is sort of sensible about society it
makes us it makes us
it makes good people be unable to have
sensible conversations and i i think
that is a problem and it's actually
there's going to be a through line to
some of the other
stories that we're going to talk about
uh but moving forward
because i am having this live uh
get-together this live meet and greet
this live happy hour tomorrow
and again if you want to join me in
socal in los angeles live
actually get to shake my hand you can go
to reubenreport.locals.com i'll be
announcing it for subscribers only a
little bit later today
well our governor here gavin newsom as
you know we are the last right now the
last state that has indoor dining still
closed so
i just want to be very clear this
weekend in la it was 80 and sunny
it was a absolutely perfect no cloud in
the sky
no humidity absolutely perfect weekend
and we do not have indoor dining we have
outdoor dining we limited
okay we get it there's no science behind
any of this and the rest of it well
gavin newsom who of course
was caught at french laundry one of the
most expensive restaurants in the united
states with 22 other people eating
indoors in the midst of all this
their bar bill was fifteen thousand
dollars yes the bar bill was fifteen
thousand dollars
well you're not going to believe this
but he posted uh a tick tock
with george lopez inside a restaurant in
a county where indoor dining is banned
you guys are freaking genius let's take
a look
how do i find out if i can get a
vaccination
george you got to go to my turn.ca.gov
wait a minute thank you governor it's
wonderful to be a surface george
okay so first off they're indoors
they're not supposed to be inside a
restaurant there's a little question as
to
whether they were actually eating or not
but let's let's show the
the photo real quick this was shared by
chef andrew gruel who's been one of the
most outspoken fighters against
lockdowns he's the owner of
fish restaurant at oc so there you can
see that there's a bunch of cups on the
table it appears that people were
drinking and probably eating
and they're inside the restaurant i mean
you're not supposed to be inside the
restaurant except okay you can come back
to me you're not supposed to be inside
the restaurant
except if you're using the bathroom so i
actually ate outdoors for the second
time in a year
in los angeles the other night we ate
outdoors and then i was able
to go inside the restaurant to pee and
then i came back outside and had dessert
um but it appears he was doing
something inside which you're not
allowed to do uh and it's
oh and by the way george lopez's mask is
falling below his nose so it's just like
the endless
cascade of [ __ ] from these
ridiculous human beings
who don't live by the rules that they
want you to live by it's just
absolutely endless which reminds me that
if you did not see it on friday we did a
panel
all about the craziness of california
and i thought that rick grinnell our
former ambassador to germany who's been
hinting about a run for governor
i thought that he was gonna maybe
announce
on the show he kind of hedged a little
bit although he
at cpac he was also at cpac he kind of
didn't didn't say no to it let's put it
that way but
comedian and my friend adam carolla
he kind of said he might just do it that
things have gotten so bad in this
ridiculous state that he might
run for governor so it's very exciting
that we've got almost two million
uh signatures on the recall to get rid
of gavin newsom we only needed 1.5 but i
tweeted this this morning and i was
thinking about this
if you didn't watch this show or if you
didn't play along on twitter or wherever
you get your news outside of mainstream
would you have any idea that there's
even a recall of gavin newsom happening
not just that a recall is happening but
that the recall has hit
the number of signatures required to
trigger the recall and not only that
it's gone above and beyond that by about
25
has cnn spent one minute could some of
you that are internet sleuths out there
could you do a little research on espn
maybe go to cnn.com do a little uh
do a little search in there and see if
cnn has done absolutely any reporting
on this i mean think about it the
governor from the biggest
state in the united states with the most
electoral votes
you know it has one of it's something
like in the top 10 economies of the
entire world and it's just the state
within the united states
um has a recall happening for the
governor and nobody's talking about it
except
those of us online which you think that
might have something to do with why
they're always looking to ban people
online because we're the ones that talk
about reality you think there's a
connection there
i'm starting to think about it anyway i
will say one other thing on the on the
recall situation
i am not i am not
completely ruling out a run for governor
david and i had a long talk about it
uh this past weekend and my main thing
is
why would i want to do it like i i like
i get
why someone like me should probably run
and i would as i've said before
i would run on complete whatever newsome
says
we're going to reverse it right and
we're going to cut budgets for
everything we're going to cut taxes for
everything we're going to get the
government out of everybody's lives like
all of that stuff but my main thing like
the idea that i would it would be 4 am
and i'd be sleeping and it's like
tuesday morning at 4 00 am and the phone
rings and mr governor
there's been an earthquake and it's like
or mr governor there's a problem with
that
like what do you want me to do like that
would be maybe i would run that would be
my campaign slogan
dave rubin what do you want me to do
about it like that would kind of
be it because i i don't know that i
really want to do it but what i will do
i promise you
i am going to stay in california at
least as long as it takes to get rid of
gavin newsom
so my hope is that some better
candidates some people who really
want to do the nuts and bolts will get
in there and i will gladly support them
and get rid
of this buffoonish clown but you know
what people i don't want to only bash on
california because there's other places
where ridiculous things are happening
and massachusetts just jumped up a
couple notches
because boston public schools have
suspended
advanced classes for grades four to six
amid concerns of racial inequities we've
got a couple
quotes here from you this first one is
from wgbh.org
a selective program for high performing
fourth
fifth and sixth graders in boston has
suspended enrollment
due to the pandemic and concerns about
equity
in the program gbh news has learned okay
so they've suspended
you know classes that allow for students
of a certain
academic rigor to be separated from
other students
partly because of the pandemic but also
because of that magic word that we keep
hearing
equity well they go on to to say a
district analysis of the program found
that more than
70 percent of the students enrolled in
the program were white and asian
even though nearly nearly 80 percent of
all
boston public school students are
hispanic and black alright so let's
pause there so
if you if you look at that at just the
very sort of surface level you might say
okay we've got a real problem here and
perhaps there is a problem at some level
if in the higher functioning classes the
classes that you have to have better
grades to get into
you're having this proportion of white
and asian students that is
this and yet most of the school
population is black and hispanic and
they're not getting into that now we can
have all sorts of discussions on why
that's happening
does it have anything to do with the
family unit does it have anything to do
with culture does it have anything to do
with study habits and all of these
things does it have anything to do with
big government programs
that have incentivized the breakdown of
the family all of the stuff that larry
elder and thomas
and others have talked about but we're
not going to talk about that right we're
just going to talk about
equity so in essence what they have
decided to do
is blow apart the idea that if you work
hard and get better grades you should be
in better classes because we can push
you harder
you know there's a there's an episode of
the simpsons very early on this is maybe
season four
or season five where bart is struggling
in school
so they put him in the slower class
right and then there's kids like
eating glue and picking their nose and
everything and bart looks at the teacher
and he says let me get this straight let
me get this straight
uh we're in the slower class and you're
going to help us by teaching us even
slower
and in essence that is what equity
is so we're going gonna just say okay it
doesn't matter if you work really hard
and you're and maybe you have your god
gifted
with some great intellect and your
parents help you study and all that
stuff
we're just gonna keep everybody in the
same thing so that it looks like we have
equity so we'll have 33 white people 33
black people 33 hispanic people will all
be robots equal equal equal
you see why this is a problem so to
eliminate you know
i remember when i was in high school my
school uh i went to a pretty good high
school it was a blue ribbon high school
we were
my parents and the whole community was
very proud of that it was a public
school
you know these days i don't know how
anyone could send their kids to a public
school
but we had the way we broke it down was
there was track one that was the best
track so if you were the best
academically you were in track one
classes
and track two was was the middle and
track three was the lower one and i
think there might have even been a lower
one beyond that
i was in mostly track two classes and i
was usually kind of at the higher end of
the track two classes
and i had a couple things like social
studies in english
which i was good at that i was in track
one classes i wasn't particularly good
in math or science so i was in track two
in that um and i had friends that were
in some
track three and some track two and it
was pretty rare if you were you know a
bunch of track ones and then a track
three
but you'd have they could then say oh
you were good at different things we can
help you in different things you'll have
different competition in different
classes
if you really care about this one thing
and work very hard at it you might get
better at here
this idea that equity will fix
everything
it's it's not going to be equity to
raise everybody to the same level
it will be equity to destroy people to a
certain level and they'll just
constantly be saying okay we want
everybody equal
so it's like well you can't get
everybody to the best
so but what can you do you can
definitely take the best and get them
lower
at least force them to be lower
superintendent brenda
casilius had this to say there's a lot
of work we have to do in the district to
be anti-racist and have policies
where all of our students have a fair
shot and an equitable
and excellent education well she's
saying it right there she wants them to
have a fair shot out of an
equitable education equitable
just as kamala harris tweeted out in
that ridiculous cartoon two days before
the election
equitable means we'll all end up in the
same place so we'll have a bunch
of very very average people and the
system
will actually discriminate against those
who succeed
based on their skin color so that if
you are an asian student who is
succeeding and working hard and all
those things
sorry we're gonna have to punish you
just like harvard makes it harder for
you to get in there
why are we doing it because we like
diversity we're tolerant you know we
like
equity it it really is seriously
dangerous stuff
and uh you know i mentioned on the show
last week and i've
written about it before and you guys
know david and i are working on
expanding our family and we we've had
some hiccups but we got a little bit of
good
good news this morning and we're going
to keep moving forward with that
but i know without question even if i
have to
work for many more years than i would
ever want to work for like i am
in no way sending my children to public
school it would be impossible at this
point
and you know one of the things and i i
wrote it in that book that's over my
shoulder about defending liberalism
one of the things that that enabled me
or allowed me
to continue calling myself a liberal a
classical liberal an old school liberal
was that i did believe in some level of
state education right so this is where
generally more conservative people at
this point are for school choice they're
for charter schools they're for private
schools they're for home schooling
i've tried to stake out the position
that one of the roles for government
is public education i think that's a
that's an honorable goal
but i think the ideas of of critical
race theory the ideas of social justice
and equity
these things are so dangerous so
infecting destroying absolutely
everything
that how could you send how could you
send your kid
to a public school to be brainwashed to
hate you and think
i mean this woman this superintendent
brenda it's like brenda
if if there's such racism at your school
maybe you should look for another job
what have you been doing all these years
brenda did you just get the job i'm
guessing brenda
probably had the job for a couple years
was she doing anything about racism why
is it that in the last school year i
know in 2020
we didn't have much school but in 2019
why wasn't brenda screaming about all
those white people getting too good of
an education
i mean brenda brenda come on you see you
see what i'm saying here
these people are ridiculous but in any
event it makes it more difficult
for me to defend public education like
how how can anyone
if if this is what's going to happen and
when we have you know the department of
education a giant federal program that
will be infected by these bad ideas and
then send all these bad ideas down to
the states
how could you as a responsible
send your children to these schools and
then and then of course
you add the zoom element to it and just
every other thing that's depressing kids
and and disconnecting them from each
other and everything else it's like we
really we're in dangerous times folks
we're in dangerous times but speaking of
dangerous times at least joe biden's in
charge right
because that guy knows what's going on
well joe biden was giving a speech this
weekend
and i know i could play these clips all
the time and often we discuss
before the show you know okay biden
forgot what he was saying biden didn't
know where he was biden looked scared
and went off stage the wrong way or
puttered around for a while and it's
like i don't want to do it all the time
but i thought this particular video from
this weekend
was was disturbing it at several levels
so
well just look uh i think he's getting
on a plane he told me a little
last he came in to see me last event and
representatives
uh cheryl shirley jackson lee
al green sylvia garcia lizzie pinelli
excuse me panel and uh what am i doing
here
i'm gonna lose track here and uh
what am i doing here i'm gonna lose
track here
all he was doing was reading names off a
teleprompter
what am i doing here i'm gonna lose
track here look i am not
belittling cognitive problems i am not
mocking people with dementia all or
alzheimer's
my grandma had dementia and when i was
doing stand-up in new york and my days
were a little free because i usually
worked at night i spent a lot of time
going to doctor's offices with her
we went to geriatric
doctors we went to all of these
different clinics like i've seen what
the medications do all of that
stuff okay so i'm not diminishing that
but
it is very obvious that the leader of
the free world
has fairly severe cognitive decline
and as i've been saying for a long time
that is not the scandal
the scandal is everyone knows it dr jill
biden knows it and she's abusing him
barack obama knows it hillary clinton
knows it kamala harris knows it the
entire apparatus
of the democratic party knows it joe
biden
has access to the nuclear codes do you
know that one of the things
one of the symptoms of dementia is
erratic behavior
is sudden bursts of anger i mean really
like if you want to just like go with it
like you see where this could all end up
in a horrible place
so the scandal is not that there's
something wrong with him we all know
that the scandal is the non-scandal the
scandal is the fact that nobody talks
about it it's not on cnn
it's not on msnbc you don't see these
you see these clips again
you see them on twitter you see them
in the in what is the real reality but
is
but is supposed supposedly the the
alternate reality right something like
that like that
is why this is so dangerous that's why i
feel like it's worth playing those
things
look i know that reading a teleprompter
by the way is not the most fun thing in
the world you know when i do the ads i
do them off the teleprompter so right
now i can look directly in the camera
and we have a teleprompter set up there
everything that i do on this show
is off the top of my head i mean i have
a couple notes here just so i know what
order i'm doing things in
but i do these things off the top of my
head so i basically talk to you guys for
a half hour i know that i have four
topics i want to get to and then when i
read quotes specifically i have to read
it off the property
reading off the proper actually takes a
little bit of skill and it's not for
everybody so
i'm not sitting here saying that you
have to read off the prompter
perfectly by the way i flub things
sometimes sometimes the prompter moves a
little faster
sometimes it could be a little
herky-jerky whatever it might be we
all read something you could be reading
something to yourself and re-read a
sentence and go
i miss that word or whatever it might be
i'm not making about any of those little
mistakes
that was though a man reading
off a prompter and all he had to do was
read a series of names and then suddenly
what am i doing here like if you don't
think that's a problem if you can't see
that
then man then you're lucky i suppose
because ignorance is bliss
all right guys it is a big week we've
got a ton going on with locals i can't
wait to make some announcements in the
next couple weeks like we've
really got a ton of great stuff and
speaking of locals
uh we are doing a live meet up in l.a
tomorrow night
at a bar and no matter whether andrew
cuomo the governor of new york says the
chicken wings are a meal or not i might
have chicken wings with you good people
but we will definitely have beer and
whatever else you're drinking i'll be
posting the location for subscribers
only a little bit later at
reubenreport.locals.com so you can join
us there
and then putting aside all of that and
more importantly than any of that this
is the week that jordan peterson
returns uh perhaps not fully just yet
but
but i would say 80 percent of jordan
peterson is back
and and probably more than that actually
and we have
our two hour interview with jordan is up
right now at reubenreport.locals.com the
video's up
the audio is up part one with jordan is
up on youtube now the full will be
up later but it was just unbelievable
truly unbelievable
like i honestly don't even have the
words for it to to uh
connect with him again and and see
his mind and and his honesty and his
level
of dealing with the struggles and the
fame
and the addiction and the physical pain
and everything he's been through all
these years
coupled with like all of the good stuff
too like all of the good stuff and there
was plenty of good stuff
and and i hope i seriously hope and i
know this may sound a little
a little over the top but you know we've
had such chaos right
the book 12 rules and the new book uh
they're about going
from chaos to order we've had such chaos
for the last two years
and i think before jordan went away he
was adding such
order to the world i really do think he
was and i can even feel it
even for me having him back having that
interview posted reading your comments
about the way he helped you in your
personal life i know it because it's the
same way he helped me
i think we could start adding a little
order to the universe so if
uh if you're ready to add a little order
to the universe like time is of the
essence why not right now
so anyway part one is up on youtube
right now full episode up at
rubinreport.locals.com i'll see some of
you guys
tomorrow night in los angeles and that
is all
hope you enjoyed the show see you
tomorrow